we are into the next division of Isaiah
this great chunk of material in chapters
44 to 48 and pretty soon almost
immediately we have several poems about
this figure Cyrus King Cyrus the head of
the Persian Empire this Empire that's
going to come in and just reshape the
whole known world this wheel has been
captive in Babylonia Babylonia is gonna
fall to Cyrus and the language that God
is using of Cyrus is quite striking
chapter 44 verse 28 he's God calls him
my shepherd in chapter 45 verse 1 you've
got this royal language of the deity
taking the hand of the chosen king let
me ask you about Cyrus how is he one of
God's agents what's going on here with
him he certainly is one of God's agents
and of all of the agents we've looked at
a number of different agents so far in
Isaiah as the way in which the Divine
Will gets worked in the world this one
has got to be one of the oddest ones
it's one thing to talk about the
Assyrian King Sennacherib as the agent
of punishment on Israel it's quite
another thing not just to talk about the
Persian king Cyrus as the agent of
Israel's return to the land that is the
fulfillment of the promise to Israel but
to give Cyrus royal titles the kinds of
language that you referred to calling a
Cyrus my shepherd this is language that
God is using of Cyrus shepherd is a
traditional royal title it's one that is
given to Kings and they have the
responsibility to shepherd their people
to take care of the Sheep and it is
Cyrus is going to rebuild Jerusalem yeah
it's not just capture Babylon and punish
Babylon because of what they did to the
Israelites but it's going to be God
Cyrus is going to be the agent
of the people's return to client is
going to enable this and indeed
historically this is exactly what
happened it is under Cyrus's rule that
israel is allowed to go back and fulfill
the promises that we've already had
given to israel in chapter 40 I would
think that would be a hard pill for
people to swallow it's a very high manu
exodus how about a new moses from within
israel one that's a member of Abraham's
posterity not a foreign who they can
really like to see that as a sort of
local agent and indeed chapter 40
envisions that it envisions this group
being someone to lead the people back
god is personally going to lead the
people back jerusalem is being
commissioned to be an agent in the
proclamation of its own salvation these
are all internal means of proclaiming
and fulfilling the promise what we have
here is the idea that god has now chosen
cyrus to be the active agent here and
not only that god is going to do a lot
of other things for cyrus in chapter 45
he is actually called The Anointed of
God
God has anointed him to be king this is
language traditionally used of the
Davidic rulers well anointed yeah
and that is Mashiach he is the Messiah
this is really strange language one
worries a little immediately about
whether the second Isaiah sees this as
the fulfillment of a royal king to come
we've already looked in those early
passages and we thought that might have
to do maybe with a zakiya but certainly
a member of the Davidic line that
Messiah is going to come from the line
of David this seems to be totally
counter to all of this God is going to
do lots of things for Cyrus and give
Cyrus the Babylonian Empire together
with all of its treasures not
surprisingly this seems to have
generated a good bit of opposition even
within second Isaiah's own community and
there's a lot of language here that
seems to be responding to the
actions this is such a strange idea do
you think that it's so strange that it
even called them to question God's
goodness I mean verse 7 speaks of God is
one who creates darkness or even creates
evil I don't think that is meant to be a
negative statement it's a probably the
most troubling theological statement in
the second Isaiah and yet what it is
saying is first of all and we've already
seen this that this is part of God's
plan Cyrus is somehow part of this plan
that God has at work in the world and
for that reason we already know that
there is no way in which that plan is
going to be thwarted this is going to
happen so God says I am God and there is
no other beside me there is no other God
God is now more or less explaining to
Cyrus who it is who's commissioning
Cyrus to do this so that even though you
don't know me they may know that is
everyone from the rising of the Sun in
the West and to the West there is no one
except me and then this ultimate
statement of a monotheism I am God there
is no other i form light and i create
darkness I make good and I create evil
that is the logical extension of a
monotheism and you don't get it anywhere
else except right here this is the first
radical statement of that kind of
monotheism and there is obviously a
great deal of objection to this line so
much so that not only does God have to
convince Cyrus God apparently has to
convince other people as well in verse
nine woe to you who strive with your
maker the earthen vessels with the
potter does the clay say to the one who
fashions it what are you making or your
work has no handles woe to anyone who
says to a father
what are you be getting this all seems
to be directed at challenges to this
idea which is
difficult to live with can one accept
Isaiah's theology here we know that
people have difficulty with the idea
that the world is somehow totally
determined and that God is responsible
for this in some way or another that was
not only a hard position to accept in
antiquity in the Isiah community it's a
very hard idea to accept now and whether
or not we have any easier time with this
than the audience that I say it seems to
be addressing here is an open question
but the thing of wonder if if there's
not also that were positive spiritual
insight here if if God is one who seems
to be almost amoral certainly
inscrutable creating darkness raising up
Syrus who is not the logical candidate
for a redeemer the one of the effect on
human beings is that one realizes that
there's very clear limits to human
thought to human ability in some ways
it's pushing one back into a stance of
vulnerability and humanists and that in
some ways is a pathway to salvation I
mean it's it's not your normal thinking
about how how God brings salvation but
it it is a possible way of thinking
about salvation that may well be and it
has to do with the arguments that seem
to be going on back and forth in this
text about the suitability of agents and
God's power and how these things relate
to each other how the human community
fits into God's plans I think of God and
the community and how God saves them I
do want to at least raise this this
language that's used at the very
beginning of this division about God as
a redeemer because that terminology
comes up more than once it does indeed
in it I'm talking about verse 24 yeah
chapter 44 that says the Lord you're
ready
who formed you in the womb and so on and
this redeemer like this is a favorite
title used of God in second Isaiah the
Redeemer language is interesting because
the first thing that it points to is the
the orbit of the family the concept of
redemption is a legal concept and it was
set in place in order to allow things
like property and people to remain
within the family it's a way of
preserving the family and so when people
redeem property they pay for it against
the debt in order to include it in the
family to keep it in the family
similarly if people are sold into
slavery they are redeemed and there is
an obligation of family members to
redeem them and bring them back so that
the family can again behold this in a
way is an incredible statement we've
we've gone now from talking about God
and covenant relationship to an idea of
God as family and God is going to redeem
Israel in exile in order to maintain the
integrity of the family and so the the
notion of the group of history lights
that is going to enjoy this concept of
redemption is very much behind this term
and anytime you think about it you have
to think about redemption as God's
effort at maintaining the group of which
God is personally a member and this sets
into bold relief the way in which
subsequent groups of the people of God
churches synagogues and so on think of
themselves as family together but also
family in which God is a active
participant